today I would like to make an appeal to
the European singers to men and women of
culture to join the debate on the future
of Europe we need them I think far too
much of the conversation that we are
having is with citizens as consumers in
purely economic language as economic
units rather than citizenry in one way
Europe has fulfilled its original dream
we are living in peace and we are
trading only that trading isn't enough
peace is a stationary state once you
have peace you cannot have more of it
but you can always have more trade and
more growth we need to continue to tell
the story of Europe like a book you
cannot always stay in the first pages
even if the first pages were extremely
beautiful my second line you possibly am
sorry
is beyond cool it's not your party not
the governorship moo-hyun leadership
self-esteem that seems terrible in
online version of sport baggage
eyelashes are over / the only thing we
need to be radical about is not giving
in to any form of radicalism that
requires courage the only thing that can
make Europe a success is what lives in
the hearts and the minds of the citizens
one of my works which was called stories
one and you have a 12 different
good-news-bad-news scenarios and this is
like one of the things which was written
there you have this tiny little robe
which says the story a good end of a
story and the bottom of the story
and this is my own personal narrative as
long as I have in my hands the little
rope and I do know that I have the bat
and the good hand in my hands I can keep
writing we need to create that emotional
link between the citizens of Europe and
our Europe
nodoby amo capira Nakamoto same question
que me precipitation la ropa por - it sa
sa ancora influent a dishes even el
mundo accuracy sorry Fran men Tata a in
fluent despite national differences we
hear similar demands in the streets of
many European countries active
citizenship is one of the positive
collateral results of the present
developments we do it in Medina Avenue
deserve to Questor deserve total Aramco
machines us a little push to deserve
Tony giorno acuity pointer a apart
opieop you need a Adam activist posición
a competition in a Europa the vessel
trolley trolley persona I think the
people who actually enjoy Europe now
speak up the Erasmus generation is time
for them to speak up is not enough to
spend time across Europe to intermarry
and to travel as I do
Europe is a Europe
you